please tell me I'm not the only one who
was secretly hoping for Queens song who
wants to live forever to start playing
the woman who lived new Doctor Who
episode not really the second of a
two-parter but a direct follow-up from
what we saw in the girl who died we have
the return of Maisie Williams some eight
hundred or so years since the last time
we saw her living it up as a highwayman
and doing pretty well for herself all
things considered and I like this
episode overall I think I liked it on
about the same level as I liked the girl
who died amazing Williams gives a more
notable performance in this one than she
did in the last episode and she was fine
in the last episode as I said but you
really felt the weight of her
performance in this one because she did
an excellent job of not letting her own
physical age as an actress
keep her or hold her back from selling
the weight and the age of this character
but after a little while I really kind
of forgot how physically young she was
until you know they'd have a shot of her
standing next to you know a grown adult
actor and I would kind of go oh yeah
that's right she really did embody that
older sense that older spirit and the
weight of pain and things like losing
children losing loved ones feeling alone
not being able to remember everything
which i think is a wonderful plot point
that's something that I don't think I've
ever seen done in Doctor I've seen it
done in in books a few times Douglas
Adams did it in one of the dirt gently
books the idea that you know somebody
can live for a really long time but the
brain only holds so much memory I really
liked that it was just her and the
doctrine that Clara didn't factor into
this episode at all I mean aside from
the fact that as I've said repeatedly
I'm kind of done with Clara it was just
really nice to have him to sort of laser
focus on this girl who's he impacted so
immensely and just the fallout of what
he did and not having someone else that
he has to explain it to or somebody
who's got to put it into perspective
just it's just him and her and they got
to work
so if there's a weak point to this
episode it's that the actual plot is
kind of bog-standard not just for Doctor
Who but for sci-fi shows in general for
decades I mean it's a very old trope guy
who's after something and says it's for
this thing that seems fairly innocuous
but turns out it's for a bad thing I
mean this this is beyond a standard plot
the episode I think more or less gets
away with it though because ultimately
the plot is not the point we're here for
a character study we are here for Maisie
Williams character and to spend time
with her and to get to know her and we
do get that we get that very well
executed it's just that even taking into
consideration it still feels like it's
just too generic for its own good when I
think of other episodes that focused
heavily on the supporting character
things like Vincent and the doctor or
the girl in the fireplace those both had
stronger stories in addition to really
solid character study work that said all
there are some good elements I really
did like Sam Swift that specially you
know standing up there just trying to
run out the clock and get the crowd on
his side that would that was just
wonderful and fun and it wasn't
gratuitous either it served a purpose
too especially when the doctor points
out you know we need the mayflies we
need the people who embrace every moment
that they have because they know it's
precious and I really did like that
conversation between him and her in that
tavern afterwards because I wasn't quite
in my mind coming up with whoa why won't
he take her with him but I think the way
that he explained it just worked really
well I like the name drop for Captain
Jack Harkness I wish I could say that I
think that's kinda lead to something I I
don't really I think it was just well
you know that's obviously the other
immortal character that we've got in the
show yeah sure let's name-dropping but
it's not it's nice to think about the
two of them running into each other that
would be very cool I do hope we see
Maisie Williams character again and I
think that hint that we caught at the
very end with the her showing up in the
selfie is an indicator that maybe we're
not done with her and we'll get more out
of her it's one of those things where I
wish secretly sheshe could become
something like River Song where she
would just get dropped in every now and
then and doesn't get overused but
unfortunately the problem is because she
is still young she's not gonna you know
retain that same look she's they have
every year going forward she's gonna be
a little bit older she's gonna look a
little bit older and since they've
established eight hundred years she
didn't physically age that doesn't work
so whatever they're gonna do with her
they kind of have to do this series
maybe out of stretch they couldn't drop
her into series 10 but I think beyond
that they're not gonna be able to keep
using her I think the note that things
ended between them was really
interesting I'm intrigued to see what
it'll be like the next time they meet
each other that's now six episodes into
the series not a bad step yet so I guess
we'll leave it at that did you catch
this episode if you did what were your
thoughts on it whatever they were drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]